The Joe Rogan experience.
So you are running for something now.
What are you doing? Um, I'm gonna
go, I've said that for nine years.
Quite consistently. I would like to say,
uh, that I was going to run in 2020.
We had set terms in our politics,
like you always had,
you've had a full year.
We arrange it into a five year,
but then we've gone
back to the old system,
which is where the prime minister of
the country can choose when they have an
election and it can be
anywhere up to a day, you know,
the next day after the election or, uh, up
to five years later. So we have no idea.
Like, so the prime minister
can decide, you know what,
we'll have another election in two weeks.
Yeah.
And they wouldn't do that for them.
But you know,
like we had the general action of 15,
2015 and then 2017 having
been in for only two years.
Um, Theresa May was persuaded
that if you go for lecture now,
you're going to win big.
You can want tons of extra seats and then
we'll be able to do whatever we want.
But in fact they lost seats
and that actually, so you know,
sometimes they grab it sometimes. Um,
you go in there fourth, there's a,
there's a traditional thing of going into
the fourth year because if you've got
all the economics going,
everything's pretty good. Okay,
let's go now we've got 40,
you've got a year to spare, but let's
go in the fourth year and we can, uh,
cause we know we're in a good place and
then you have to allow I think six weeks
for an election campaign.
But yeah, that's, we do that.
I think other countries do that,
but I am sure to an American you go,
that sounds crazy. But anyway, that's
what we've been doing for some time.
What are you going to run for a member
of parliament for some constituency
hopefully in England would be my
thing as opposed to, you know,
the kingdom because there's whales
and Scotland. And is this a step,
are you going to move further along the
line or you are going to eventually? No,
that would be once I stand for an
NP than I would at Glen. The Jacks,
I don't know if you know Glenda Jackson,
she did this well on in shot.
So like you know about him cause he went
away and then came back to the creative
work that he was doing to doing films.
But he went away for seven years.
So I will go away for a period of time
and put my career to hibernation and just
do partings or two poachers.
But you have a set period of time
where you're going to do this and then
afterwards you're gonna retire. No,
I would do it. No set period of time.
I just got and go off and for as
long as I can, as far as I can.
And then I come back when I choose
to come. Oh No, stand up. No nothing.
During that time you could do stand up
if you're raising money for charity.
If I'm raising money for the
Labour Party, I party. Um,
I think that would be allowable.
I think my constituency members wouldn't
mind that if I was raising money for
constituency.
Um,
but if I was just doing it for myself
less, well you can write books,
you'll have to write books and
the articles, it's all a bit hazy,
but I'm not sure if you have the same
system in. We have a similar system. Uh,
my friend Doug Stan hope was running for
president briefly kind of as a lark and
uh, realized that he really couldn't
do stand up because if he did stand up,
he would have to allow equal time for
everyone else who wanted to perform,
who also had some,
like his stand up performances were
then thought of as political campaign
performances,
something along those lines.
It was like some weird bullshit that he
was going to have to navigate that he
decided to just back out of it. Yeah,
but he was bullshitting the entire time.
We're just doing it for fun now. I ain't
going to do it. I ain't going to go in.
I think a lot of moderate people don't
go and I consider myself a radical model.
I do radicle things with the model of
message and they've already done a number
of things like that and my life.
So I'm just going to take that in.
And what's your goal?
My goal is to try and encourage my
country in the world to go in a positive
direction. I think, um,
I've been saying this politically that I
think this is our last century on earth,
or it's our first century on it.
I think next 80 years is for everything.
We're going to choose everything here.
We're either gonna wipe ourselves off
the planet or we're going to make it a
fair world for 7.5 billion people where
you have a right to have a fair old
enough democracy and transparency,
enough money to live a life,
to have a family.
Not everyone know billions of people
living on $1 a day or $2 a day.
So I think we need to get to that
because then immigration raises its head,
your country, my country,
every country in the world.
And that's all people moving around
because they haven't got enough money to
live on or they haven't got of security
because there's a war civil war.
And if we could get beyond that, then a
lot of those problems drop away. So, but,
and going into politics and talking
about a global vision of the future in
whatever is,
is slightly,
it's very difficult thing to do
because people couldn't say, Oh,
you've just asked for that. How is
that helping this, this global vision?
But I just thought we seem to be
trying 1930s politics again and,
uh, in political area. So I
thought, well, I ain't gonna,
I ain't gonna look for a vision,
a positive vision of the future.
And I know when I came out as transgender
and I'd be fine if there was no way I
could imagine anything.
I didn't know where it was going to go.
I just thought I can need to go
out there and need to argue those,
discuss at least try and set up a
positive image version, you know,
cause uh, you, I don't care
what age you are, but I think
it was 51 51. So, you know,
I'm 57. So remember the earlier years
of our lives, it was just so out there.
Transgender,
you didn't talk about it.
They were gay and lesbian
people out with transgender.
It was like crazy out there and plays
well at that. Hell are you on about,
and that's what it was when I came in
the middle of that. Yeah. It wasn't a,
it wasn't a, an easy thing,
but I just thought, I'm not
going to do special forces.
I'll do this. Civilians, there's
a hilarious group of choices,
special forces or transgender,
what I did the,
the civilians special forces to fight
on the streets in the audio people and
yeah, and be, and it's all
mental, isn't it? If you're,
if you're in a isn't any way the same
because people are shooting bullets at you
in the end,
people are dying and getting blown up.
So I know there's a massive difference
there, but everything in the end,
it's psychological. And, um,
if I wasn't going to do that,
I'm just gonna try and do this,
and I would take risks in these areas of,
of,
you know,
I'll go out and people say things in the
street or whatever they do and do that,
and then I'll run the math as though you
were going out knowing that you might
have to be in an altercation. Yeah. I,
I'm was sure that was going to happen.
Teenagers at this point and screaming.
Yeah.
Okay.